[Music]
this is Susquehanna nuclear power plant
in Berwick Pennsylvania
there are two nuclear reactors here each
with a cooling tower and together they
generate power for about two million
homes but right now one of the reactors
is shut down
the unit one reactor is getting a new
more efficient turbine every time a
turbine is shut down it puts stress on
the grid the plant has to buy power for
its customers from another source
now if everything goes according to plan
the outage will cost about 10 million
dollars but if anything goes wrong we
could be talking serious money nuclear
power plants like this one use the
process of nuclear fission to make heat
the heat converts water into steam and
the steam expands into a chain of
spinning turbines that turn a generator
and that makes electricity we're here to
fix the high-pressure turbine getting
the old turbine apart is complicated the
outer casing alone tips the scales at
110 tons
next the 42-ton inner casing comes apart
finally we can get out the old 80 ton
rotor then the new one goes in every
lift has to be done with surgical
precision the inner and outer casing
finish the job there's nothing
lightweight about taking apart a nuclear
power plant turbine this top piece alone
weighs 110 tons about as much as 50
pickup trucks stacked on top of each
other and it has to come up perfectly
level they're going to the four corners
of the lid wrapping around the horn this
is actually the seam right there this is
the top case this is the bottom casing
when we start to apply force to this
lift we're gonna peel it apart right
there and that's where the potential
contamination is gonna be coming from
right out inside that crack getting
really close to seeing this thing flying
out if it comes up crooked it could
scrape metal off the blade carriers what
they call galling I can actually see
turbine blades inside there if little
bits of steel get left behind they may
find their way into the new turbine it's
a relief when the outer casing is clear
but we're not out of the woods yet this
casing has spent the last two years in
constant contact with steam coming
directly off the radioactive core
radioactive material could be falling on
the floor right now
as it moves across any area of the
ground that it covers becomes
potentially contaminated area so as it
comes towards us we're all gonna have to
push away
contamination is generally easy to clean
up as long as it stays on the outside of
your body as soon as the cover passes
overhead they'll get out all these swabs
and they swab up the deck underneath it
three days into the fix we've just got
the top off and that was the easy part
next comes the 42 ton inner casing then
the old rotor will be replaced with a
new more efficient one they're almost
ready to take out the old rotor this is
going to be tricky because one end of
the rotor is a lot heavier than the
other end if the bearing starts coming
up we'll stop take a dead blow knock it
down
Jeff lays it out for the team how the
lift will go down alright guys be safe
we got a plan time to rock and roll
there's also a really tight fit so we're
gonna have to lift really slowly in the
first couple feet to get it picked out
of there
finally it's level that's close enough
to pick it out
and they wrap it up to trap in any
contamination
this rotor supplied over a million homes
with electricity for five years the new
rotor taking its place along with some
other upgrades will get more power from
the same amount of nuclear fuel we go to
ships that pass in the night that's the
old rotor just coming in here's the
brand new rotor that's waiting to go in
right behind it this is the heart of the
beast as precise as a Swiss watch only
this thing is German this is the big
moment we're gonna pick the rotor up
drop it into the place where it will be
working for the next few years we like
to say lower the rotor we hate to use or
drive I never use the word drop crosses
man yeah it's worth five million dollars
not including the cost of having to shut
down the plant
there's a lot hanging on getting this
piece in without a scratch
[Music]
it's a beautiful piece of steel now this
is pretty significant engineering feat I
mean they're trying to locate this thing
within three dimensions it's easy to get
it off kilter and scar the sides and if
they scar it it's got to come out
there's no option for failure here
yeah it's a high-tension moment yeah
because this is if something drastic is
wrong
now's the time it's gonna show itself so
they'll go to the hardware store for
another one of these
nice the turbine rotor is finally in
position it's almost time to put on the
last two pieces they discovered that the
new inner casing was just a little too
big to fit inside the outer casing so it
has to be pared down by just a bit
it's soon ready to go on to the Roda a
lot of weight to muscle around it's got
the slide in right next to the blades
without touching them or scarring them I
got to get a picture of this these guide
pins set up that'll keep the orientation
of these rotor blades and the stationary
blade carriers perfectly vertical but we
slide it down we don't scar anything up
that piece is in place no mishaps one
more to go there's our big case and this
huge piece of steel is kind of like the
back to the watch we already put in all
the watch works now we just put the back
on and then we'll be able to start it up
I gotta say I'm impressed yes ooh man
hey really amazing I'm glad you're out
there making power for people that's
right got to be done that's right
somebody's got to do it don't go out I'm
here to help
mission accomplished right on time
pretty soon there'll be water vapor
coming out of that other tower and
they'll be electricity rolling out over
the lines that means I'm good to go